what's the scariest animal in all of
chess you might think the dragon but no
the Hedgehog Wow
the scariest animal is in fact the
hippopotamus and today on review we're
gonna be taking a look at how naina
dignity tried to handle the hippopotamus
against her opponent in the Karen's cup
Chrissy yep
of course everybody knows the hippo goes
efore g6 there are many move orders to
the hippo this is just one d4 Bishop g7
Knight f3 d6 Bishop c4 e6 castles and
then this is the the signature structure
of the hippo black does not push any
pawns to the fifth rank and said keeping
all of her pawns back on the sixth lying
in wait under the water and ready to
strike at the opportune moment and then
we see Krista actually develop her
Knights not to the standard squares f6
and c6 but instead behind the pawns
keeping everything hidden beneath the
surface white plays Bishop b3 this is a
little bit of a prophylactic move
keeping in mind that black may play d5
at a later date white doesn't want her
bishop to be attacked by this pawn brick
black then castles white supports her
center with c3 and now black plays
Knight d7 kind of completing the
development of the hippo some very
ambitious hippo players will also feel
in Quetta the second Bishop but this
might be going a bit far white continues
her development with Bishop f4 black
goes ahead and plays h6 and then we see
white do actually a very smart thing
which is to respond to h6
with h4 so this move is keeping an eye
on kind of all of black's pawn breaks
right we see white controlling the
center both with their pieces and the
pawns and so this is how she's
preventing these pawn breaks from black
in the center but then on the Kings side
she needs this extra pawn the Age pawn
to counter the g5 von Drake as well and
so now Krista continues with
6y continues development with night bd2
now Krista actually brings out her other
Knight to c6
perhaps the not not the greatest way to
actually get developed here when in fact
of course this night could have gone
here in one move in this night could
have gone here in one move and instead
both of them have in fact taken two
moves to arrive at their final locations
and now not it does something very
important when you have more space and
when you're playing against an opening
like the hippo mistake some players make
is they kind of sit back they they move
their pieces forever and ever and ever
as the white player you just try to put
your pieces on the optimal squares it's
definitely and that's definitely one way
of playing but in doing so you're always
going to have to look out for black
trying to eventually break out and
that's something that black might try to
do here play it quickly say you waste
just a little bit of time then you play
your x1 and black plays a move like
Ricky eight or actually immediately can
break free with E 5 and so this is what
you don't want to allow as the player
with more space if your opponent can
kind of break through using active play
like this and in fact using tactics with
a net h5 and now recapturing actually
probably with the bishop or the knight
now we see all of a sudden blacks Bishop
has been freed along this open diagonal
this Bishop now has some opportunities
to get developed along this diagonal and
blacks position is actually looking
totally fine here
so this is something you really have to
be wary of when you're playing against
an opening like the hippo and so how do
you stop a 5 here is a very relevant
question and not I answered this
question by playing e5 herself
of course after e5 black can't play e5
and this is the way that nana chose to
restrict the black pieces and so because
this pawn comes to e5 the black Bishop
will never be able to develop via this
diagonal because this pawn is in the way
so if I've securing that space advantage
black takes on e5 white takes on e5 you
see 97 Queen e2 supporting this advanced
pawn now b6 now white simply brings the
rooks to the center with a d1 black
plays Queen e7
Bishop c2 is a nice reroute of the
bishop and now after a 5 we see rook e1
of course just getting the rooks into
the game this Bishop comes out to a6 and
the Queen comes to e3 now pressuring
this H pawn and now black plays the move
h5 cracking under the pressure of the
whites white pieces attacking this H
pawn black simply moves it out of the
way and at this point Chris is actually
in quite a bit of trouble what Nana has
done over the past few moves is really
really instructive on the surface it
looks as though she just brought her Rix
to the center moved this Bishop back to
another diagonal and brought this Queen
up a step but what these moves are
actually doing is pointing out that the
black camp is kind of split and this is
because Krista has much less space here
so due to this advanced pawn on e5
pieces like these two Knights are
actually unable to get back to the Kings
side in order to defend the king in
addition to that this bishop in this
rook are also kind of locked to the
Queen side they're not gonna be able to
help defend the King very well and so
what Nana has done is brought this
bishop to attack the Kings side brought
these pieces to attack the Kings side
she already has this Knight so he was a
fly here this is fun she already has
this knight ready to attack the Kings
side this Knight can jump in as well via
e4 and these rooks are prepared to even
lift themselves and join in the attack
as well so we see the entire white army
prepared to shift to the Kings side
whereas there are no fewer than four
pieces for black kind of locked out of
that side of the board and this is the
huge advantage that space really gives
you it gives you this flexibility to
move between sides of the board and then
your opponent should be unprepared for
at least one of those sides of the board
due to this lack of space in fact
karissa actually missed a chance here to
help her position out a little bit of
course when you have less space this is
kind of this can kind of be alleviated
by training off some pieces and so
that's what she should have done with
this move Queen c5 then after queenie
form that can actually insist on the
trade with a move like cleaned e5 and
after something like trades
white is still doing quite a bit better
here but black isn't getting checkmated
immediately which is really the
important thing so Quinn c5 would have
been a nice try from krysta instead we
saw h5 defending the pawn this Fisher
comes to g5 now the Queen has to come
out to c5 but white has this extra
option of Queen f4 and now this pawn is
well defended the queen is safe on f4
but actually this pawn isn't well
defended enough i spoke too soon black
actually captures it on the next turn of
course counting is is always difficult
chess three defenders three attackers
chris is doing okay but now this gives
white the opportunity to bring her final
pieces into the attack with Knight e4
and now we see all of these dark squares
coming under fire Queen c6 is played
Nana goes ahead and takes off one of
these nights we see Bishop takes e5 from
from Karissa hitting this Queen not as
simply retreats with tempo on the night
of course you don't really want to move
this Knight out of the way because then
you're gonna get hit with Knight f6
check and the dark squares are
completely falling for the black king
here so this pawn or this night staying
on d7 Krista plays Bishop c8 to defend
it and now Nana makes a pretty serious
mistake here I'll let you at home try
and find the best move and my little
starter hint for you is that you need to
find some way to get this King near or
get this Queen near this King this is
your goal in life in this game and so
that's how you can kind of arrive at the
best couple moves here
they're both aimed at getting this Queen
into the action what Nana did was
instead play Knight g3 which is kind of
missing the point
you want this Knight here to attack
these dark squares to get at this King
all right hopefully you at home have
found the move it is of course Bishop h6
and then let's say Chrissa plays a move
like bishop will not but should be seven
let's say she plays some kind of
nonchalant move like gosh don't even
know okay Bishop g7 here the point of
Bishop h6 was a
course to get this clean into the g5
Square where it can also influence these
dark squares
you're not playing Bishop age six really
to take this rook for example if black
plays a move like let's say just work
the eight for example you're not
actually really looking to take this
rook here although white could you're
looking to play Queen g5 then you're
gonna take this night and you're gonna
play Knight f6 and you're gonna win the
game this is the idea of whites play
unfortunately though not I missed this
instead playing ninety three once again
taking away a key attacker of these dark
squares
Chrissa actually continued the game with
rook b8 and here not a missed a tactic
which is very strange because I thought
she was setting up this tactic by
putting this n on g3 she could actually
just capture this pawn on h5 and black
would really be unable to recapture it
due to this move well this is very very
nice move actually Bishop f6 I was gonna
say Queen d3 of course there's f5 here
blocking off this diagonal so instead
you played Bishop f6 the idea being that
after this Bishop gets captured Queen h6
is going to be unstoppable mate on the
h7 squared if you move this rook
you're gonna hit with Bishop not Queen
age 7 and after this tactic that I'm
sure everybody has seen before black
would be checkmated so some missed
tactics there by Nana but it's no
worries she instead plays the the move I
mentioned earlier Bishop h6 and after
Bishop f6 once again she has this knight
h5 tactic and here it's even a little
bit more clear because you simply do
have Queen d3 no this Bishop hits f6 but
it's forgivable instead she captures the
rook and from here the rest of the game
is just some pretty nice technique by
Nana she brings in the night all the way
to f6 takes off this dark squared Bishop
activates the rooks and here we see
after some maneuvering the rooks make it
to d8 and after the rooks make it to d8
we trade into this end game where the
rook is simply much better than the
minor pieces and after rook b7 this game
is is pretty much over the rooks gonna
collect all of the pawns on the Queen
side and Chrissa will be hopelessly lost
and so this is a very instructive game
actually there were two more moves in
the game this should be one
a three and then this is where Chris had
decided to resign this was a pretty
attractive game by Nana actually
pointing out how to use extra space to
your advantage and how to make sure
against the dangerous hippo opening you
don't allow black to get any of those
nasty pawn breaks that she's looking for
so once again congratulations to Krista
though on a fantastic tournament at the
Karen's Cup where she had some very nice
games but this unfortunately was not one
of them thank you so much for joining me
on this episode of game review my name
is Caleb Denby and I will see you next
time